this is not about seeing the world
through rose-colored glasses like this
is known that you have the power to
overcome the Thorns what is the science
behind positivity like why is this so
powerful when you are busy and stressed
what happens is this dizziness and
stress signal sends a signal to the
reptile part of your brain you don't
care about positivity you're thinking
how could I just get through the day we
are addicted to our phones at the same
time most of the content that we are
engaging with is negative how do you
think about combating that remember it's
an outside circumstance it really has no
power over you if you truly understand
this you've had the benefit and pleasure
of working with tons of uh people who
are on a different level what sets them
apart in your mind all right guys bang
bang I'm here with John John you've got
a bunch of education and experience in
teaching people mindset how to be
positive and how to change their lives
and their organizations one of your most
popular Concepts is this idea of an
energy bus uh I see you even got the
shirt on right now uh talk to us a
little bit what the hell is an energy
bus and why is it so important for
people able to understand this inside of
these organizations it's really funny
people asked that many years ago when I
wrote the book like what is an energy
bus got rejected by over 30 Publishers
because no one understood it and could
get it and then eventually it came out
started to get out there it got
popularized and now a lot of
organizations businesses and sports
teams use it it's all about staying
positive in the face of negativity there
are 10 rules for the ride of your life
so life is like an energy bus you're the
driver of your bus you choose the kind
of ride it's going to be and the energy
you bring to your life to your work to
your team will determine the success of
that and a big part of The Energy Bus is
negativity energy vampires that will
sabotage your journey and we have to
deal with the negativity that exists on
our teams and our organizations and also
in the world just look on social media
look at what everyone is dealing with
right now with negativity how do we
overcome that negativity to create our
business to build our team to ultimately
have this new idea that we're launching
and get it off the ground overcome and
build something amazing every
entrepreneur has dealt with negativity
that will sabotage your team this is how
we overcome it with these rules from The
Energy Bus so if we dig a Little Deeper
here on this these energy vampires I
think most people are able to identify
them at some point it may not be obvious
at first but over time they identify how
do people overcome it is it something
where you try to convince an energy
vampire to stop and actually start
contributing positive energy is it just
go around them is it get them out of
your life like how do you deal with an
energy vampire there are many ways and
and many possibilities based on the
situation first and foremost it starts
with you what is your energy and how do
you deal with the energy that you're
facing and dealing with for instance you
got to be more positive than the
negativity that you face Gandhi said I
will not let anyone walk through my mind
with their dirty feet so think about
that so when you deal with the
negativity you have to be more positive
than negativity I remember telling my
dad my dad was a New York City police
officer undercover narcotic Hey Dad I
want to be a writer and speaker I I
found my calling his response what the
heck you want to do that for that's a
load of junk that won't amount to
anything he was this again Italian New
York City police officer tough guy
fighting the drug cartels in the streets
of New York like like positivity like
writer speaker like who does that he
didn't see that several years later I
get on the Today show and the show was
called get energized today it was a four
week series did this series I impacted
people it actually went really well but
first first episode I walk out of the
studio my dad calls me on the phone he's
like your mother I saw you on TV you
really made a difference we're so proud
of you we always knew you could do it
you know he remembered being negative
and I think that's a a great lesson I
didn't listen to him I had to be more
positive I had to have a greater vision
of what I wanted to build what I wanted
to create so first and foremost it
starts with you knowing you have to be
more positive but then you got a team
you're leading others Nick nurse coach
of the Toronto Raptors friend of mine he
put an elephant on his desk it was a
reminder that we're going to deal with
the elephant in the room like we're
gonna have the hard conversations we're
going to deal with the issues that exist
we're not going to let anything get
unchecked or or unnoticed or undealt
with and as a result of that I know the
team that year when he did this they had
some really hard conversations if they
don't have that conversation or those
conversations they don't win a
championship but they did and they won
the NBA Championship that year I've
worked with the Dodgers with the Rams
and every team along the journey has to
have those kind of conversations the US
Women's Soccer Team a few years ago when
they won the World Cup they would meet
after every game and they would talk
about who messed up who need to play
better who needed to improve and I was
talking to Ali long on the team I had
her on my podcast and I said no one took
it personal she said no we all wanted to
be great together small ego big mission
so they were dealing with this at the
cultural level at the team level so a
lot of times like I work with Mark Rick
years ago University of Georgia like he
put a he put a sign on the wall of the
meeting room that said no energy
vampires allowed like we're not gonna
allow negativity to sabotage this team
and if you're an energy vampire this is
not the place for you so he was dealing
with that also head on confronting it at
the cultural level and the team level I
have guys still from that team that
remember that that have gotten to be
very successful in the business world
and it's so funny they said you know
what John I was a vampire I walked into
coach's office I said coach I'm not
going to be one anymore I'm going to be
more positive and I watch that player
because coach actually told me about the
story of the player who went and said
that watched him play made several key
plays during that year that took them to
the SEC Championship Game as a result of
that and now they're successful leaders
so you're helping people when you do
this at the team level the cultural
level I also work with a lot of schools
and there's a lot of negativity in
schools I work with districts at the
district level trying to help leaders
get rid of the negativity that exists
and again this works where
you also are dealing with the cultural
level but then you may have to coach
someone so someone is being a vampire
you have to coach them you have to
Mentor them you have to guide them you
have to talk to them to help them get
better but then the ultimate rule is
this if they're not willing to get
better and they're sabotaging the
culture and they're sabotaging the team
one person can't make a team but one
person can break a team you have to get
rid of that person and let them go you
give them a chance to get on but if they
don't you got to let them off the bus
and wherever I go speak whatever company
whether it's for instance Snapchat had
to you know deal with this with with
some of their negativity and Evan
Spiegel told me when they dealt with
this they said we're going to focus on
positive leadership and positivity some
people got off the bus but it's always a
good thing because those who are meant
to be on it will be successful those who
don't won't and Doug Conan when he
turned around Campbell's Soup same thing
he had a lot of pessimists that was
hurting Campbell's Soup and they were
they were almost gonna be a a bankruptcy
case they were a takeover Target he
turned them around with positive
leadership addressing the negativity
they got rid of the vampires running
been positive people and literally
turned around the company as a result of
that
science behind positivity like why is
this so powerful what is going on when
you have this positive mindset versus a
negative mindset we know from this from
the scientific level like at the health
level it actually increases your
longevity it builds up your immune
system it allows you to to live longer
and a healthier life we also know at the
leadership level you're better able to
Garner support and people to you when
you're more positive you attract people
and the scientific level the frequency
level positivity is a higher frequency
than negativity which is a lower
frequency the thing is there's a lot
more negativity in the world so it seems
like it's more powerful because there's
more of it but actually it's at a weaker
frequency or weaker energy but
positivity is a is a higher frequency
and we're talking about real positivity
of course and also positivity unites
whereas negativity divides and think
about a team that is a United Team
they're a stronger team they are a more
powerful team think about a team that
has division or negativity they're a
weaker team so you can look and see how
positivity will be the glue that makes
it a team stronger whereas negativity
will weaken and provide a team at every
level we also know that you're stronger
believe it or not when you're thinking
more positive thoughts they've done
research on on people who actually think
Loving Thoughts versus fear-based
thoughts and you actually lift more
weight when you're actually thinking
higher thoughts and Loving Thoughts
versus fear think about fear fear is a
negative emotion but love is a positive
powerful emotion love is more powerful
than fear we know that and so again it
seems like fear is powerful but love is
even more powerful than fear so if you
look at it every single level from a
scientific perspective positivity is
better able to bring people to you help
you lead in a more positive way and also
get people to perform at a higher level
are you are you going to perform better
when you're positive or negative I've
never seen anyone say you know I need to
be more negative to perform better I
know I need more positivity to be at my
best because negativity is always coming
in and we have to learn how to overcome
the negativity to reach our highest
level but I think too many people in
this world equate positivity with fluff
like oh they roll their eyes oh Mr
positive fake positivity this is not
about feeling the royalty Rose Colored
Glasses like this is knowing that you
have the power to overcome the Thorns
it's not about ignoring reality like
it's okay to say this sucks this stinks
like right now during covet it was a
really tough time where where we might
be heading to a recession like this is
tough what we're dealing with or
inflation what are we going to deal with
that how are we going to deal with this
like crypto for instance you know the
collapse okay this is not good right now
but how do we find a way forward I think
that is the key Alan malele who turned
around four years ago during the Great
Recession they were losing 14 billion
dollars he had been profitable in a few
short years it was like it was like one
of the greatest leadership Feats in
history and he defined his leadership
style as positive leadership and what he
said was positively just bring the team
together they rally the team and they
always find a way forward through the
adversity through the challenge and
through the setback that's the kind of
positivity I'm talking about what is
positive leadership like you've
mentioned that a couple of times now
what exactly does that entail does that
just mean showing up to work with a
smile on your face saying rah-rah and
getting people excited or is there
something else so I wrote a book the
power positive leadership and what
positive leadership is it's a way of
thinking it's a way of leading it's a
leadership style but we really shouldn't
stay positive in leadership in the same
sentence because if you're a great
leader you will be a positive leader so
what do positive leaders do they set the
vision where are we going and why are we
going there so there's a vision that
everyone is moving towards and
everyone's hopeful about you do have to
have a hopeful Vision as a leader you
also have to have a purpose like why are
we going there we don't get burned out
because of what we do we get burned out
because we forget why we do it so like
what is that why so positive leaders
lead with that vision and purpose they
also lead with optimism and belief I
work with Dabo Sweeney and Clemson
football for the past 11 years he has
built that program on optimism and
belief so a leader will believe in their
team more than they believe in
themselves and as a positive leader
leadership is a transfer of belief so
you believe but does your team believe I
mean Steve Jobs wouldn't be defined
necessarily as a positive leader in
every category but in this category of
optimism of belief a vision of what he
was building it was pure optimism it was
pure belief of creating the future we
know how he he distorted the reality of
the people that worked for him saying
Steve there's no way we're going to be
able to create the software this
Hardware in this amount of time he would
say get your head around it and everyone
who worked with him said he was able to
distort their reality from from negative
or pessimistic or even realistic I'm
just being a realist to to Optimist to
believing what they can create and what
they could do and they said every time
they believed and created what they
never thought was possible so that's
what that's what positive leaders do
they believe in their team they transfer
that belief to others and they have this
optimism of what they're creating and
also that positivity and belief as we
said earlier helps them overcome the
negativity that they face positive
leaders also
deal with the negativity that exists so
that's the other thing like this is not
Pollyanna positive we're going to deal
with the real issues a lot of leaders
ignore the negativity that exists and it
winds up sabotaging the culture
sabotaging the team but positive leaders
they don't attack
they don't attack people they attack
problems and that's a big difference
here like we're not going to attack you
we're going to attack the problem I'm
not gonna criticize you I'm gonna shout
praise and Whisper criticism to help you
get better but we're going to address
the energy vampires that exist we're
going to have the hard and difficult
conversations in order to get better so
that's a big part of positive leadership
and then it's about relationships like
building relationship as a team it's not
about just a state of mind that makes
you feel better or think better like
mentally tough like resilience mental
toughness big part of positive
leadership but it's not just that how do
I build relationships so that we can so
that we can take action together and
create more success and we share four
C's in that framework communication
connection commitment and caring so I
gotta communicate with you whether it's
avoiding communication negativity will
fill it I gotta connect with you develop
a relationship I gotta show commitment
to you think about this you'll never
have commitment without connection so
the more connected you are as a leader
and as a team the more committed you
will be essential essential for
leadership and then Karen do I care
about you and if I care about you guess
what I'm going to practice love and
accountability this is like the Hallmark
composite of leadership love and
accountability Alan Mullally said you
know John told my team I gotta love you
up but I gotta hold you accountable to
the culture the values the principles
and the standards that we have created
we got the standard and if you're not
meeting the standard we're gonna have
conversations about you not being the
standard but I'm going to support you
and encourage you along the way to meet
that standard love and accountability is
like essential for leadership one of the
words that comes to mind as you're
talking is enthusiasm and in the
military there was two things that I
always heard that uh just resonated with
me the first was enthusiasm is
contagious uh and the second is that
enthusiasm can overcome pain and the
quintessential example would be uh the
drill sergeant asking somebody to do
something and they take off running and
screaming with enthusiasm even though it
may be fake enthusiasm uh this ability
to trick your mind into a certain State
uh that would then allow you to
accomplish the goal or to endure the
pain how do you think about enthusiasm
and this ability to actually use
enthusiasm to either create positivity
or to go ahead and trick your mind into
being in a certain state where it can
accomplish things that it might not
otherwise be able to accomplish
in my mind it's not about faking it till
you make it it's about acting like you
belong because you do it's about getting
into the desired state that you truly
want to have by getting excited about
life like the more you get excited about
life you'll get a life that is exciting
when you're taking on a tough task and a
tough challenge it's your perspective I
think this goes to perspective like how
we see the world determines the world
that we see is it a challenge or is it
an opportunity do I focus on the
challenge or the opportunity every
challenge is an opportunity to learn to
grow to improve to get better when I
arrived at the Tampa Bay Lightning a few
years ago they had just lost in the
first round of the playoffs and so they
were reeling they would pick to win the
Stanley Cup and they lose the first
round so they're like what's going on
what's wrong they're trying to figure
things out and there I am and they
constantly were talking about last year
I said listen we can't talk about last
year let's talk about this year let's
not Look Backwards let's look forward
let's not be bitter let's get better and
then
I gave them research that shows that
teams that feel like they're defending
something don't do very well but teams
that feel like they're attacking a new
opportunity do great and so they began
to attack a new opportunity it changed
everything change their mindset their
perspective how they were seeing their
season and they're playing because they
were so focused on defending this status
of an elite team and we have to live up
to that now it's like no we don't have
to defend anything we're going to attack
an opportunity every game to win as we
know they won the Stanley Cup won the
next year and made it to the finals this
past year so they changed their
perspective and mindset that changed
everything so whether you want to call a
trick in your mind or or changing your
perspective and changing your approach
that is the key in terms of how we have
to have a positive mindset sometimes
through our toughest times I tell people
all the time like I learned this from
Chad Wright a former Navy SEAL and he
was telling me a lot of guys you know
don't make it to be an ABCO because they
don't make it through hell week he said
they don't make it through hell week
because they're dreaming for it to end
they're long enough to be over he said
the guys the guys who make it just want
to make it to breakfast and I realized
what he was telling me that like that's
the key to getting through that
challenging time or any challenging time
it's not worry about tomorrow like it's
wind today how am I gonna win today and
show up and win each day and what does
that mean for me like how do I identify
what winning today means to me and you
got to choose that approach and that
perspective like for me it's I'm going
to stay positive I'm not going to allow
negativity to get the best of me I'm
gonna get better every day I'm gonna
find ways to improve and grow I'm going
to find ways to encourage people so to
me enthusiasm is you are passionate
about something there's a entheos right
filled with the Divine there's a spirit
that is moving through you and you have
this perspective first this thought
process that then leads to the energy
and the emotions that you have as a
result of the perspective and the
thought process and then from there that
manifests itself in that physical form
of ultimately what we build and a big
part of this
you got to know that you create From the
Inside Out not the outside and I think
like I always go back to the root of
things like what's the root that causes
someone to be successful and we live in
a world that loves to focus on the
outside they focus on the numbers they
focus on the challenges they focus on
the expectations but we never create
from them we always create from the
inside out your spirit your passion your
love your joy your work ethic your drive
so you're always creating from within
you creating the world outside of you a
great analogy of this is like is a
the carrot the egg and the Coffee Bean
think about the carrot you put that in
the boiling hot water and it gets soft
and it gets weakened put that egg in the
bowling hot water what happens to the
egg it gets hardened so when life is
like a big pot of boiling hot water or
you're dealing with hell week for
instance and it feels like you just want
to give up you could be like yeah you
get a hardened heart and just no longer
care or be bitter angry and frustrated
it could be like that carrot where you
get weakened fearful stressed and
anxious don't want to be the carrot I've
been the carrot in my life by the lab I
have failed at times in my life when
I've I've fallen like during the.com
crash I lost my job during the.com crash
that's a whole other story and I learned
a lot about overcoming challenges like
that I become a coffee bean in my life
now especially during covid learn so
much during the.com crash that when the
covet hit I was prepared for that the
coffee bee when it's put into hot water
think about that it transforms the water
it makes coffee it's not defined by its
circumstance it defines its circumstance
it's not impacted by its environment
that coffee being transformed forms its
environment and that's what world
leaders do that's what game changers do
pop this is what you do like you're
you're a coffee bean you're changing the
world like what you do by this podcast
by how you interact with people every
world leader is ultimately a coffee
being impacting the environment not
defined by it one of the most
interesting Concepts that you've uh
talked about is this idea of a high
state of mind I know you're writing a
book on it now talk to us a little bit
what is a high state of mind and how
does it differ from a low State of Mind
okay one day you're in traffic and it
bothers you the next day you're in the
same traffic and it doesn't is it the
traffic that's making you feel a certain
way
no of course not right it's not the
traffic two kids grew up in the same
neighborhood one kid comes out a
neurosurgeon the other kid comes out
living a life of crime we often blame
the neighborhood though we say it's a
neighbor that caused that kid to be a
certain way or think about remember when
you're in school and get a paper or
project too I hated those papers and
projects and you couldn't get your head
around it but then all of a sudden you
had a Moment of clarity and you bang the
paper out was it the paper that was
making you feel that way no it's always
our state of mind so when our state of
mind is high the circumstance happens
and you know we rise above it we move
forward when a state of mind is low the
same circumstance happens and we we
don't move on we get crushed by it we
get affected by it so it's always our
state of mind so what characterizes a
high state of mind a lot of clarity a
lot of focus a lot of positive energy
when we've been in the zone where we're
just flowing that's the high State of
Mind the low state of mind a lot of
clutter a lot of thought a lot of worry
a lot of fear a lot of anxiety a lot of
doubt if I do two circles one with a
thousand dots and one with three dots
which mine will perform at a higher
level almost everyone knows and everyone
gets this the one with just a few dots
think about it less clutter higher state
of mind so we have to understand that
these thoughts and life are always
affecting our state of mind but we have
to maintain a high state of mind so the
next question people ask is okay how do
you get to a a high state of mind and
that's with the teaching and that's what
the book is all about understanding
there's an ebb and flow to thought
and once you understand how thoughts
work you can actually return to a higher
state of mind it's like the roller
coaster you're on this roller coaster
all the time and the roller coaster is
going down for instance and first time
ever on a roller coaster
and you think the roller coaster is
going to crash because you don't know
the roller coaster goes back up so as
you're going down you're gonna crash
what would you want to do on that roller
coaster you would want to jump off and a
lot of times when people are in a low
state of mind they want to jump off the
roller coaster they want to escape
that's why people play video games it's
why they drink it's why they do drugs
they're trying to escape the feeling
that they have that's why people have
additions we're trying to get to a
feeling and we're in this low state of
mind so we do all these things to try to
feel better because we really want that
higher state of mind or you're in that
roller coaster and you're going down and
you're at that low State you think
you're gonna crash now you're searching
for answers you're trying to fix things
you're trying to figure things out like
a baseball batter goes over four over
three and then over four again that
baseball batter now starts to think a
lot more they start to have revved up
thinking or a quarterback right now I
know a lot of quarterbacks work with a
lot of quarterbacks they make a couple
bad passes they start to think too much
as a result of this and so now they're
thinking a lot instead of just playing
they start thinking affects their play
more clutter Lower State of Mind more
insecurity more doubt and now the
circumstance happens and they get
crushed by the circumstance so it's
never the circumstance it's always our
state of mind the key is don't jump off
understand what's going on and then ride
that wave right back up that's one of
the techniques and there are many more
that I share in terms of how to have a
high State of Mind mindfulness is great
for a high State of Mind meditation is
great the new book I'm writing explains
why meditation and mindfulness actually
work because they lower the amount of
thoughts that we have that give us a
higher state of mind and then there's
fear and negativity and all those
negative thoughts that we have actually
always lower our state of mind so you
have to understand that every day this
is a battle between these negative
thoughts that are lowering your state of
mind and how you confront it how you
overcome it to have that higher state of
mind so you can perform at a higher
level so you can lead better so you can
have more clarity more confidence more
courage and the key is to get to a place
where I have connection
where I have confidence Clarity and then
that leads to courage so that's really
the case does that make sense it makes a
ton of sense and I guess one aspect of
life that has changed drastically over
the last you know couple of decades or
even centuries is uh we are addicted to
our phones or computers our tablets and
it's awesome we're getting these
dopamine hits and there's notifications
and there's Doom scrolling on various uh
news feeds and things like that at the
same time most of the content that we
are engaging with or that we are
consuming is negative or is something
that puts us in this negative low State
of Mind how do you think about combating
that is it just put down the phone put
down the computer or there are other
tricks or hacks that you have to kind of
share with people that can really help
them just avoid so much of that
negativity and low State of Mind
activity uh which is just our electronic
devices this episode is brought to you
by eight sleep good sleep is a game
changer and the eight sleep pod is the
best sleep machine I sleep on it every
single night a great night of sleep
allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself and eat sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep such a great
question because everything that we do
from you know the social media from the
media from what we're reading it could
affect us but remember it's an outside
circumstance it really has no power over
you if you truly understand this so the
key be a Jedi and really get to that
point where you understand none of this
could actually impact how I feel let me
give you a little story
um I'm speaking to the Oklahoma City
Thunder there's Russell Westbrook Billy
Donovan I'm walking across the court I'm
about to speak to the team and Billy
says hey John we were just wondering
what has a bigger impact on the team
home field advantage in baseball or home
court advantage in basketball what has a
bigger impact on the opposing team
thought for a moment I said neither when
you know the outside is just noise and
we don't create from the outside in we
created from the inside out I talked
about Inside Out talked about the Coffee
Bean the power's on the inside that's
how we create it shouldn't matter what's
happening on the outside and Russell
said that's what I think he said 98 of
the guys in the league believe in home
court advantage so it affects them he
goes I know it isn't true so I just go
do what I do and play my game and that's
really the key knowing that having that
understanding now I'm sure there's been
times what he's been playing where he is
affected by the noise because he's in
that Lower State the circumstance
happened and then it affects them but
it's always remembering the truth
strategy is important but remembering
the truth is even more powerful when you
understand that so I should be able to
look at social media
and as I'm starting to get this feeling
of feeling divided by the way the word
anxious literally means divided at its
Greek root word so the more anxious I
feel the more divide I feel where the
more divide I feel the more anxious I
feel okay so now I'm feeling divide I'm
feel feeling separate from everybody
everything myself right I don't feel
connected I don't feel that Oneness I
feel divided anxious nervous and secure
so I'm reading the social media I have
to return to the truth of Oneness and
maybe do something that that gets me
back to that people do yoga people do
meditation people do prayer I take walks
of gratitude every morning because the
research shows you can't be stressed and
thankful at the same time so I truly
believe it's about having practices that
help you get back to that state once you
keep on remembering the truth that this
outside force can affect you we got to
remember when you compare you despair so
the more we compare on social media as
well we're gonna feel like we have this
despair because we want their life or we
want their success and that's the other
thing that's causing you to feel
separate you're not looking at your own
life you're not living from inside out
now you're focusing on outside in I talk
about you know Simone biles a lot when I
speak to
um you know athletes or Naomi Osaka and
I have nothing against them whatsoever I
think it was really wrong the way people
ridiculed them when they were going
through their their mental health
challenges deciding for instance you
know Simone decided not to compete but
what really happened if you think about
it was she was looking outside the noise
she was looking at the pressure the
expectation that caused her to have a
lot of thought a lot of fear and that
revved up thinking that caused a lot
more clutter then led to the Lower State
of Mind and then her wanting to jump off
the roller coaster and escaping and you
don't want the ball in the middle of the
game when you're when you're playing an
NBA game for instance when you're in a
low state of mind you don't want the
ball we don't want that sales call we're
in a low state of mind it's how we feel
we have to understand that and so we
shouldn't celebrate them for saying the
outside is affecting me we need to tell
the truth that it's not but we have to
remind people to get back to the inside
out and see what really happens when
we're going through that so we know it's
happening now I got to take action to
get back to Oneness and it's disciplined
practices it's basically for me it's
it's walking each day it's gratitude it
might be
you know taking some time to reflect and
think every single day or read something
encouraging and inspirational or as Elon
Musk said the other day he wants to
bring more positivity to Twitter which I
think is a great idea wants to amplify
the positive so which positive sources
can I tune into as a result of all the
negative sources because if I'm tuning
into negativity every day how is that
going to affect me think of again we're
talking about energy everything is
energy there's the energetic structure
of the brain we see patterns we hear and
and relate to the world in terms of
frequencies sounds are vibrations think
about wavelengths and colors so
everything is energy and you're always
tuning into the world and I'm always
tuning into the negative or the positive
think of a plant you feed that plant
love and nourishment and life that
plant's gonna flourish your brain is
like a plant think of that plant that
you feed a lot of negativity every
single day you feed a lot of of a fear
and jealousy and anger right and
frustration you feed that every day to
that plant you talk negatively to a
plant every day it starts to wither your
brain literally will Wither by doing
that your brain is an antenna we have to
remember that the brain is an antenna
tuning into different frequencies and so
if you tune into that higher frequency
of Love Of Joy Of Peace of positivity
you're going to nourish that antenna
that antenna is going to Thrive it's
going to tune into the higher frequency
you tune into a lot of lower frequencies
it starts to damage the antenna and then
you tune into more and more negative
frequencies this is why people go down
downward spirals I am convinced again I
don't have research to prove this I want
scientists to start doing research on
this because I am convinced once we
understand that brain is an antenna we
can actually start tuning into more
positive frequencies and we literally
could have Pro training programs and I
already have one in terms of these
positive programs I create in terms of
how we continually tune into a higher
frequency and and better information and
more positivity like I can give you a
pump I can give you one strategy that I
just love that I think everybody should
do this has been a game changer in my
life and also all the people that we
teach through our leadership training
and it's from Dr James gills like he's
the only person on the planet to
complete six double Iron Man triathlons
that's a double Iron Man which means you
do an Iron Man a daily to do another one
and the last time he did it he was 59
years old so he was asked how he did it
he said this I've learned to talk to
myself instead of listening to myself he
said if I listen I hear all the fear the
negativity the doubt all the reasons why
I can't finish this race but if I talk
to myself I can feed myself with the
words and the encouragement that I need
to keep on moving forward so talking to
yourself instead of listening to those
negative voices is essential like when I
work with professional athletes I always
ask them do your negative thoughts come
from you and they're always like yeah of
course well here's my next question if
you believe your negative thoughts come
from you who would ever choose to have a
negative thought like would you ever
choose a negative thought would you ever
choose a negative thought that says you
don't have it today the future is
hopeless business is going to be
successful I'm going to lose everything
you would never choose a thought like
that so thoughts are always coming in
and we have to understand that they come
in from Consciousness no one has ever
found a thought inside of a brain I've
asked neuroscientists like hey have you
ever found a thought inside of a brain
no we haven't John no we haven't found
thoughts inside of our brain because
they exist in Consciousness the brain is
the hardware it's where activation
happens so that antenna is tuning into
Consciousness the thought comes in and
and then we have the activation in our
brain and often those thoughts are
negative and when those thoughts are
negative they start to tell us things
about ourselves and our future that just
aren't true they start to sabotage us
they make us feel insecure they weaken
us they divide us and this is what every
Champion athlete has to deal with these
negative thoughts that are coming and
saying you're not great you're not going
to win you're not going to succeed with
the knowing inside them that no no I am
here for something great I do have this
great greatness within me I prepared I
train I want to create this I have this
Vision I know what I want to build I
know what I want to be so we get this
tension always going on at the Battle
right of the positive and the negative
the ultimate battle and this is how you
win the Battle of your mind by
understanding I'm not going to listen to
those negative thoughts no I'm going to
speak truth and words of encouragement
to those Lies when I go into that battle
every day and that battle might be a
boxing ring like Jake Paul so you had
him on right it might be that boxing
ring it might be the battle of the
business world of of this of this new
Venture that you're creating in a new
market I gotta win this battle it might
be the battle in a school where we're
trying to educate kids and equip kids
and make a difference in their lives
whatever it may be you're gonna face the
battle especially as you're trying to
build a successful business you're gonna
deal with this battle you mentioned walk
of gratitude or gratitude walk what is
that
so again the research shows you can't be
stressed and thankful at the same time
so while you're walking you're
practicing gratitude and we know the
power of gratitude It's ability to boost
happiness and increase positivity and
literally uplift you with the right
positive emotions that start to to
affect you in a positive way so you
combine gratitude with this positive
walk so while you're walking you're just
saying well you're thankful for it and
what happens is you get a double boost
of energy you're flooding your brain and
body with these positive emotions that
uplift you you know rather than the
stress hormones that slowly drain you
and over time actually will slowly kill
us if we let them so every day you
create this um fertile mind that is
ready for great things to happen by
practicing gratitude I've been doing it
now for almost 20 years changed my life
I was so negative my wife was literally
ready to leave me because I was so
negative I'm 31 years old I lose my jobs
in the.com Crash how am I going to pay
the bills with second mortgage for home
20 000 credit cards I'm opening up most
Southwest Grill franchise trying to make
it work I'm crumbling from the fear the
pressure the stress I have two little
kids and man she had enough she said if
you don't change like we're over she
threatened to leave me and I had to
change I wanted to stay married and so I
agreed to change and that began this
journey of okay how could I be more
positive and I found this latest
research in positive psychology and that
changed everything
one of the most interesting academic
studies I've ever seen is that if you
were to wake up in the morning and read
three positive headlines you're much
more likely to say you had a better day
at the end of the day than if you'd
woken up and read three negative
headlines
um what are some other studies or pieces
of data around this positive psychology
that really sticks out to you or that
you've kind of incorporated into a lot
of the work that you do on the training
side with the various people yeah Martin
Seligman talks about the Gratitude visit
so go visit someone and actually tell
them what you're thankful for about them
and then read the letter to them people
who do that have a remarkable boost in
happiness by practice and gratitude and
appreciating someone else like when you
appreciate you elevate you elevate your
mood you elevate your performance and
you elevate the people around you so
appreciation is really powerful Robert
Evans you know Professor out of uh out
of Cal he also you know has done UC
Davis California he does amazing work in
terms of of gratitude and has identified
a lot of the key things that we've
talked about in terms of how gratitude
boosts happiness and starting a
gratitude Journal I believe he was the
first person to come up with that idea
to do a gratitude Journal but I really
believe also one of the key things is is
doing a success for the day so at the
end of the day
instead of going through all the things
that went bad that day all the things
that went wrong why don't you talk about
what went right like come up with the
one great thing that happened to you
that day I call it the one great golf
shot Theory because think about golf we
play a round of golf and we have a lot
of bad shots but then you have this one
great shot and that one great shot makes
you want to come back and play golf
again and again well think about life
always focus on all the bad things we
don't want to go towards a life we don't
want to attack it we want our treat from
it when it's always negative now let's
focus on the one great thing and every
day you go to bed a success you wake up
feeling like a success and now you're
ready to take on the day instead of run
from it I've done this a lot with my
kids I've seen it firsthand with them
I've shared a lot we have schools do it
all over the country and so that's a
really powerful exercise to do so
research out of the University of
Michigan also talking about in terms of
positivity like positive teams
outperform negative teams so the more
positive interactions we have as a team
versus negative interactions like three
to one or greater positive to negative
that team performs at a higher level but
the interesting thing here is if you get
to 13 to 1 13 to positive to one
negative the team actually doesn't do as
well they start to fall apart why is
that because we're not dealing with the
real issues it's too much positivity we
have to have some construction in there
we have to have some improvement we have
to have some feedback we have to have
some truth right love and accountability
that makes us better along the way
otherwise what happens is you have this
loving team that loves each other these
great feelings but we're not actually
becoming great together so that's
another key research and for those who
are married or in a relationship the
ratio from John gottman's research shows
five to one we want five positive to one
negative interaction so don't get too
confused three to one's not enough we
gotta get combined to one and that means
that the couples that have a five to one
positive to negative ratio those couples
are much more likely to to be happier
and to stay together as a result of more
positive interaction and so saying you
you and your wife are fighting a bunch
recently and you're having a lot of
negative reactions maybe it's five to
one the other way p is okay we gotta get
back to some positivity let's take a
walk together let's share what we
appreciate about each other let's talk
about our hopeful future together let's
talk about what we're thankful for right
now let's talk about
a highlight in our past our favorite
moment let's talk about things that have
Lift Us start to get back to some
positivity in your relationship to
increase that connection my wife and I
wrote a book called relationship grit
and it's about our ups and downs in our
relationship and how we almost got
divorced twice but how we stuck together
through those challenging times and as a
result of that like you have grit that
grit that makes you stronger and better
together and the connection piece and
the appreciation piece that gratitude
piece is a big part of relationships
being together and being stronger
together I love that what about uh
physiological or psychological kind of
tips and tricks so uh there's a lot of
folks who will talk about breathing
exercises there are people who talk
about meditation there's a whole bunch
of these what are things that you've
seen your clients or your colleagues go
ahead and pursue that actually had a
positive impact and were able to put
them into kind of a better mindset let's
talk about busiest and stress and how it
affects your mind affects your life it
affects your brain when you are busy and
stressed what happens is the signal from
from from your heart this busyness and
stress signal sends a signal to your
brain to your amygdala to the reptile
part of your brain if you know anything
about a reptile a reptile will never
love you right a reptile is all about
survival so when you're busy and
stressed you're activating the reptile
and you don't care about relationships
at that point you don't care about love
you don't care about positivity you're
thinking how could I just get through
the day so you can't be a great leader
when you're activating the reptile you
can't be a great teammate and a lot of
times what you'll see is people in
traffic people on social media people in
the investment World they are reptiles
going for For the Kill which sometimes
might be good for short-term success but
not really good for long-term success
and happiness so just know we're
activating the reptile in those moments
well thankfully we have this part of the
brain right here
this is the neocortex part of the brain
and when you are positive when you're
practicing uh unconditional love
mindfulness meditation prayer you're
activating this part of the brain this
is the part of the brain that's the
rational part this is where you make
decisions and research shows we have a
quarter second to override the reptile
with what I call the Positive Dog the
love and unconditional nature of dogs so
the Positive Dog can override the
reptile quarter second if you're aware
of it and you're intentional about it
but if you've ever said something you
wish you didn't say or act in the way
that you didn't want to act or told
someone they were number one in traffic
or maybe even just hurried through a
meeting what happened was your reptile
it ate your positive dog think about
that it's called cortical inhibition
this part of the brain hijacks the
rationale and that's why we say things
sometimes Under Pressure it's why we act
like a jerk sometimes it's why I
remember Alec Baldwin years ago right
went off on his daughter on the phone
and acted irrationally we've all been
there because right busyness and stress
but the good news is the more
intentional you are
the more you breathe rhythmic breathing
also with practicing appreciation and
gratitude helps you get into that more
positive State and activate that part of
the brain by activating actually the
coherency in your heart the heart is 5
000 times more powerful than the brain
think about that five thousand times and
so it is the emotional conductor this is
why if you try to practice meditation
while you're standing over a cliff like
literally about to fall you won't be
able to do it because your heart is
racing it's why some people can meditate
because they've got to actually regulate
the heart in addition to the brain and
the mind and so it starts with the heart
and the mind and the heart are really
connected in a big way this is research
from from heart math by the way heart
math.org if people want to know more
about this they are so Cutting Edge I
went to visit them in the Santa Cruz
mountains years ago when they were doing
pioneering research before anyone was
talking about any of this stuff it was
so powerful to be there to see it and
it's something that has played out ever
since seeing how this this technology
Works they also work with the the Ryder
Cup European team it's one of the secret
weapons of the Ryder Cup European team
helping them emotionally regulate
through breathing and appreciation so
you more are in the zone and you're able
to perform at a higher level so I'm a
big fan of breathing a big fan of
gratitude of meditation that helps the
physiologically and then understanding
that everything ultimately comes down to
the coherence and the energy that we
have that we're now putting out there
into the world and anything that does
that is is really key from from a mental
mental toughness standpoint resilience
standpoint and also just happiness
standpoint so think about this for a
second like this this this
um we often talk about body language
right everyone talks about body language
we have to so body language yes it helps
when you get into a certain body
language state it helps you to for
instance have more confidence when you
get into a power pose but before you get
into that pose there's an intention of
thought and energy that comes before you
actually move move into the pose so it's
not the pose that gives you the power
it's the energy and intention that moves
you into the position that allows you to
experience the emotion that you're now
experiencing so always remember it's
always energy that creates the physical
it's our state of mind that creates
ultimately the reality that we're
dealing with it's always energy before
physical and if you think of it in terms
of that way you'll start to see the
world in a more powerful way does that
make sense it makes a ton of sense what
about diet how does the food that we
consume or the liquids that we consume
actually impact our uh our mental state
and our positivity or first negativity
we know for instance research shows that
the more we eat wild salmon we actually
have better brain function and less
depression it's a great great resource
and and uh and key for me for instance
like years ago my wife almost left me I
literally started to eat salmon every
single day wild and then I also changed
around because you don't want to eat the
same fish all the time I always believe
in having a healthy diverse diet to have
a healthy ecosystem within your body the
more diversity the healthier the
ecosystem so don't eat the same Foods
all the time I believe in even changing
up your water all the time but you don't
want to have the same water the same
thing come in coming in in case there
are contaminants or things that are not
good in what you're eating so I was
eating a lot of wild salmon I truly
believe it's one of the key ways that I
was able to reduce the depression that I
was having during that time and so wild
salmon is key people talk about fish oil
is essential obviously leafy greens and
anti-inflammatory diet
is key for brain health and brain body
so I was talking to an NFL player who
you know had CTE had had pretty bad
concussions and brain damage and he
started to do hyperbaric chamber you
know therapy oxygen therapy and that
helped a lot also changed up his diet
which was huge and he brought up a great
point with concussions okay you get the
hit and the hit happens but for some
people you get hit and there's not a lot
of inflammation so you don't really have
a big issue with the concussion or any
any brain damage issue but other people
you get the hit and then there's a lot
of inflammation and that causes the
brain damage and cause of the issue it's
not about the hit it's about the
inflammation that happens from that and
how do we have less inflammation a big
part of it is by being by eating a
anti-inflammatory diet where we eat more
salmon blueberries wild leafy greens and
pineapple and anti-inflammatory foods
and turmeric
t for lowering the amount of
inflammation that we experience and have
and so the more you do that I believe it
works the same way with the brain right
the brain and the body the more you have
uh less inflammation the body the more
the body is able to heal and recover
faster so think about it when you play a
sport you put stress on your body you
get hit in your head inflammation
happens from that the more we can remove
the inflammation or have less
inflammation the body heals faster so
this is key and it has huge implications
in in everything we do and if we look at
covid for instance the covet issue was
it was an inflammation issue long covet
I'm convinced is an inflammation issue
you have a virus you have a foreign
substance come in or some outer body
come into your body it infects it and
now you body responds to inflammation
remove the inflammation and the body
will heal does that make sense it makes
a lot of sense my last question is a
huge part of that diet diet is
everything I don't think people will pay
enough attention to their diet again I'm
not an expert in diet but I do a lot of
research on diet and also I almost died
from a flu shot years ago way back in
about 2001 2002. as a result of almost
dying from that flu shot I started to
have a lot of autoimmune issues as a
result of that I could only eat certain
foods and one of those Foods I could
really only eat was salmon so so that
actually helped by eating eating it for
my brain health but it turned out it was
all I could eat eventually with some
white rice and some organic steamed
vegetables I had such poor diet and poor
digestion so I suffered like that for
about 12 to 14 years and then I started
to research all the ways I could improve
my diet and so I started to research
inflammation and everything gut health
became an expert in it for my own health
to get better healed my gut about about
four years ago finally and it's been
incredible how much better I feel now
but I still make sure I eat healthier
even even though I could still eat the
bad foods if I wanna I love that my last
question for you Tim Grover wrote one of
my favorite books called Relentless and
he talks about this concept of a cleaner
basically somebody who is so good who
has such a different mindset they stand
out from everyone else you've had the
benefit and pleasure of working with
tons of uh people who are on a different
level whether through a competition in
business or their chosen field of study
uh and kind of work what sets them apart
in your mind what have you found are the
things that actually set these people on
another level mentally and keep them
operating at the top of their game and
allow them to kind of separate
themselves from people who are obviously
very good but just may not be able to
accomplish what these very few
individuals are able to accomplish
it's what we talked about earlier it's
it's that high state of mind it's inside
out and it's in those moments they're
not worried about what anyone else is
thinking they're not experiencing fear
in that moment they're engaged in the
moment they have a lot of faith in that
moment wherever that faith comes from
for some it's God for others it's just
faith in themselves and it's that
incredible belief in that moment that
they're going to create the shot they're
gonna they're gonna make the shot
they're gonna have the win they're gonna
experience it whatever it may be they're
not worried about failing in those
moments also I'm convinced I'm convinced
they have the ultimate High state of
mind because they are loving the battle
instead of fearing the outcome I was
with the Chicago Bulls the other day
speaking and John Paxson was there John
Paxton was Michael Jordan's teammate he
said you know I was so fortunate to be
Michael Jordan's teammate I said I think
he was fortunate to be yours because if
you don't hit some of those shots he
doesn't win as many rings and has as
many championships so we laughed about
that and then he said you know Michael
Jordan loved the competition he loved
the battle he loved to beat you like he
just didn't want to beat you he also
wanted to destroy you and take away your
heart and soul so he was so focused that
he still is whenever he plays anything
else he still wants to you know beat you
in everything so he had that mindset
when he was playing and think about it
when Michael is playing he's not worried
about failing it's not even a thought in
his mind and now think about other guys
they're worried about the outcome what
is social media gonna say what is the
media saying right now what happens if I
miss a shot one of my teammates gonna
say I tell guys all the time when
they're playing I don't want you to
think about what coach is thinking in
this moment your coach doesn't want you
to be thinking about him in this moment
your coach wants you to think about what
you're doing being engaged in the moment
loving the battle and loving the
competition it's amazing when you do I
was talking to a minor league hockey
player it was a a friend of mine's son
he was really struggling he wants to
make it to the NHL but he is struggling
so he hadn't scored a goal in like six
games so he's at his wits end he's on
the roller coaster and he literally is
getting ready to jump off that roller
coaster you could tell like he was he
was at the end of his rope and so I
started talking about high State of Mind
well State of Mind helped him understand
his negative thoughts were not coming
from him choose positive thoughts and I
helped him understand that that this
fear that he had was was revving up the
amount of thoughts he had it was now
dividing him making him weaker making
him anxious causing that low State of
Mind creating that clutter and I said
all you gotta do
is get back to loving playing love the
competition love the battle just go for
it you got nothing to lose we had this
great talk I said okay what do you have
to do now he goes man I just gotta love
playing again like yeah I used to when I
was younger I wasn't worried about
making other Pros I just loved playing I
said exactly get back to that so he does
next thing you know boom six goals in
three games that's called up to the NHL
scores a goal at each one of his NHL
games it was like so awesome to see this
play out in his mind how he was
performing at a higher level I've also
shared this teaching with Dak Prescott
Damian Lillard we have had great
conversations about this and it's cool
when they can actually equate it to the
real world and see how it helps them
perform in that real world so so the
gray ones again they're gonna have
moments they're gonna be moments of fear
they're gonna be moments of of concern
moments of maybe I don't have it today
that that today but they have incredible
mindset relentlessness is a great part
of it but I would also say it's wit like
the ability to overcome to persevere to
keep moving forward in the face of
rejection failure adversity and
obstacles and what is the ultimate
driver of grit it is love because if you
don't love it you will never be great at
it if you're not loving the battle right
you won't be great in the battle you
gotta love the competition I played
lacrosse at Cornell University and so I
also shared this with the Cornell
lacrosse team this year before their
quarterfinals game and share this with
them and next thing you know they chose
to love the battle became their rallying
cry because this team would always start
slow why they're cerebral they're
Cornell guys so they're thinking a lot
of course they get all these thoughts
going in so in the beginning of the game
you watch them they're like hesitant
they're slow they're not taken to the
cage they're playing horrible they start
to lose by the fourth quarter they're
like hey we're losing let's just go for
it we got nothing to lose now they just
go balls to the wall next you know they
start crushing the game they come back
and they either would always win by our
goal or lose by a goal I said guys this
is what's happened explain to him the
ebb and flow once they saw this it
became so clear go love the battle love
the competition from the very beginning
and just go for it they did made to the
finals took Maryland to the finals in
the championship Maryland had so much
more talent and yet they battled like
you would not believe again another
example of seeing this play out it's
absolutely amazing to kind of hear uh
how much these principles crossed
throughout Industries whether it's
business whether it's sport different
sports uh or just even in your
relationships or your daily life
um it's uh it's taught me a lot and uh I
know that you've taught millions and
millions of other people as well where
can we send people to find you on the
internet uh find some of the books that
you've written or other work that you're
doing thanks Pop I appreciate you doing
this interview and just really had a
blast talking to you about it they can
go to johngordon.com
j-o-nordon.com or Twitter Instagram I'm
at
j-o-nord11 at John gordon11 and you can
reach me there find out about my books
there I recommend you start with The
Energy Bus if you're an entrepreneur
start with the carpenter it's all about
building greatness with yourself and
your team and I love you said these same
principles apply so that's what I really
love like I have five children's books
too so my books also are reaching kids
now to help them with this mindset so
they can actually deal with bullies deal
with the negativity deal with all the
anxiety they're facing we know so many
teams today that are really struggling
and by the way I share these principles
High State of Mind low State of Mind
with two teenagers this summer
two were suicidal both turned around
completely like 180 sharing this so
that's why I'm so passionate about like
this teaching and that's the book I'm
writing now to be able to get that out
there so that people can actually use
this help them with their business their
life but also for their kids because so
many are struggling I love it man all
right thank you so much for doing this
we definitely will do it again in the
future hey thanks Bob